[Musique]
le 15 avril 2020 la ville de montereau
fault yonne en seine et marne va être
témoin d'un incendie spectaculaire
touchant l'un des immeubles de la cité
sur ville
[Musique]
en fin de journée un incendie se déclare
au premier étage de l'immeuble et se
propage à grande vitesse laissant les
habitants pris au piège et livrés à eux
mêmes
immédiatement des jeunes du quartier se
mobilisent et bravent le danger en
escaladant la façade du bâtiment vont
venir en aide aux personnes prises au
piège et les extirper de leur
appartement
malheureusement une mère et son enfant
périront dans l' incendie mais grâce à
l'intervention des pompiers à l'immense
courage de ces jeunes 40 personnes
seront sauvés des flammes ce soir kamel
et karine de des jeunes héros présents
sur les lieux sont avec nous pour nous
raconter ce sauvetage exceptionnel
tu arrives qui amène ce que je peux dire
bravo
franchement alors karim bécamel
bienvenus ça y est vous êtes des héros
en fait
c'est pas tout le monde qui décident
d'escaladé un immeuble et en plus c'est
un peu pour aller sauver comme commencer
comment s'est passée en fait vous l'avez
vous étiez sur place non moi j'étais
avec des amis je t'ai pas loin ouais je
me suis rendu compte que dans
l'immobilier de la fumée qui s'en dégage
et éméché approchait que mon amie on l'a
ouvert la porte de l'aude on essaie de
rentrer dedans mais c'était pas possible
j'ai décidé d'aller chercher des
extincteurs dans l'immeuble d'en face
j'en ai distribué quelques gens essaient
de rentrer dedans mais c'était plus
possible du coup on a décidé de passer
par la façade de l'immeuble
alors si vous avez revu ce monsieur
depuis non je n'ai pas revu
pour le sauver vous n'avez jamais revu
non après le sauvetage il a été pas sans
maison de retraite pas d'accord et
quelques temps après 500 demandes maison
de retraite il est décédé
une bonne raison un poisson une vue
n'ont rien mais bon non plus
est-ce que vous avez une décoration
quelque chose de da par deux oui moi
j'ai été décoré par le maire de ma ville
mon distribuer la médaille d'honneur de
la ville
pas mal mais total ou
c'est moi j'étais au travail et
ça va vite si vous vous la mairie tout
ça ils sont donnés de l'été bien moi n'y
a pas de problème moi je conchie sauf
les gens savent utiliser a subi un délit
comme dû sauver mon père et ma mère et
ma serre moi je laisse pas vivre
comme ça ça fait dix années c'est pas la
première fois moi je suis 15 ans
j'habite là bas mais moi je suis comme
ça mais la question qu'on se pose bien
quand ça arrive ça est ce que nous on le
ferait
est-ce que vous avez vous l'un d'entre
vous il a eu un comportement héroïque
une fois dans sa vie à sauver la vie de
quelqu'un moi moi en agent mais là
j'aurais été bien incapable en nageant
en a dans sa sirène oui mais il y avait
une dans le lac léman j'ai une amie qui
est parti et qui pensent que comme c'est
un lac bah c'est pas dangereux et on
veut la clémence et et y est c'est une
mer intérieure et ça peut changer en 10
minutes et double était très très loin
très très loin de la berge et elle a
complètement perdu pied et je me suis
rendu compte de ça eh ben j'ai plongé
pour la première fois de ma vie je
déteste ça et je les jeux les ramener et
elle sait à jamais à aucun moment les
gens m'ont applaudi quand je devais
ramener sur la berge et elle sait
absolument pas rendu compte donc elle
m'a insulté
bernard bonjour six mois il m'est arrivé
un truc mais c'est pas vraiment un acte
héroïque c'était sur une route des
landes vous savez j'habite comme à près
de bordeaux le pilat etc et il y avait
il ya eu l'accident j'ai devant moi
quand je suis arrivé mais la route pau
mais totalement paumées j'ai vu qu à l
accident il y avait les phares allumés
vrai que ça fumait un peu et il y avait
une jeune fille allongée et puis un cerf
qui était en train de souffrir elle
avait tapé le cerf bon évidemment mais
là elle était paumé ciel d'abord elle
était évanoui donc qu'est ce que j'ai
fait dans ces cas là mais c'est pas
héroïque je les ai évidemment pris dans
les bras en faisant très attention j'ai
essayé de la réveiller un peu pour que
je sais pas s'il avait mal et ses habits
jeu direct à l'opinion qu'ils regardent
konya l'accident a parlé mettent en pls
faute surtout à
van damme est juste quand on se décide
de se lancer dans l'ascension d'un
immeuble qui est en flammes est ce qu
est ce qu on pense au danger et on peut
penser au pire parce qu'il y avait aussi
une chance de tourner des cash flows est
de tomber la barre explosion de brûler
les doigts on va lire moi au début j'ai
pas j'ai pas pensé ça moi au début j'ai
rentré pour sauver les gens c'est lui
qui m'a donné papa gérant très direct je
commence le 2 dans ce bloc est gênant
pour qu'ils rentrent dans le bâtiment
beaucoup définis quand j'arrive pas
j'avais un tunisien dont le blocage est
sorti c'est un jeu sorti mais après moi
je le sais pas comme louis gemelli
poubelles dit j'ai pensé et j'ai ramené
trois poubelles les gros poubelle
j'aimais bien 1 2 et a monté un
programme dans le
sas et une présence d'esprit frais
dans la peur fait l'impression et
l'émotion bravo franchement
[Applaudissements]